it's interesting with these with these
um uh ai beings um that that you know
get really really close to crossing the
uncanny valley but never quite get there
is i think the the notion that um
that kind of an entity is always gonna
be a puppet right it's never going to
have true life so so
you're there's always going to be people
who are able to kind of intuitively
sense that something is off
um i think you get kind of the same
thing honestly with like super produced
music there's there's a feeling that it
gives you that that um that you can
detect and so i suspect that
you know like the the reeler that these
that these um
uh
that these puppets become
you'll always be able to detect that
something is off
and it's like yeah but listen to what
i'm gonna i'm gonna say something that's
gonna that's gonna
what if that oddity they deify that
oddity
that's where you that's that's it
because that's the the experience of the
sacred is is something which is not
totally you which is pulling you
into something else and so
you can use you could use this weird
uncanny sense
to create the the to create a kind of
perversion of the sacred
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
so hello everybody i'm here with ken
florence and daniel townhead
that ken and daniel wrote an article
recently for the symbolic world blog on
egregors who wrote there were two
articles actually
and for those who have been following
the discussion on my channel with john
verveiki with paul vander clay there's
this big discussion about the question
of agenda beings or
transpersonal beings or there's all
these ways of trying to name them the
idea that there is some kind of agency
beyond the human level
of course for religious thinkers this is
something that isn't surprising to us
but for
uh people coming out of materialism or
people who have lived in a secular
materialist world uh it's difficult
people kind of perceive it i think more
and more people can see it but they're
struggling to find the right words to
distinguish between these different
types of manifestations of agency at
something which is beyond the personal
level and so
i was using people were using words like
egregor and using different ideas and i
critiqued it and ken and daniel really
did the work and went into the terms
research where their history was in
terms of uh you know who came up with
these words how they've been used
historically and they came up with some
pretty interesting and good critiques
about my own takes about different
people's takes and so i thought it would
be a great opportunity to continue this
discussion with them so guys thanks for
thanks for coming on thank you man great
to talk to you thanks for having us
all right so i i would say
both of you one of you together uh maybe
start by laying out the basic idea of
what you came up with in the articles
and what the critique was um in general
well yeah i'll basically go through the
first the first article
so um in our first essay we took a look
at the concept of vegrigorz and it
basically means watchers are wakeful in
greek and is named after the fallen
angels for the book of enoch
but we see that they originally referred
to spiritual beings that were invoked by
occult groups but this concept developed
into an imagining of agriculture as like
a manifestation of collective will or
collective behavior
and in this way they became entities
that were associated with the idea of
emergence
so after we established this we then
attempted to describe christian
cosmology as it is held by yourself in
the symbolic world community and see
that because reality is conceived as a
continuous hierarchy of being with an
origin and purpose in god purely
emergent beings or entities can't really
exist
but at this point in writing the essay
we discovered a pretty exciting detail
we found that a quote in a 20th century
text that had been very influential in
creating the idea of the emerging
agricore
excluded an important paragraph and that
this paragraph described the creation of
tibetan buddhist toppers which the
author asserts are equivalent to every
gods
in ways which any follower of yourself
and matthew would recognize his behavior
which is kind of giving body to higher
beings
and so uh this in brief along with some
other evidence
leads us to simply reassert the identity
of regregors with the watches of the
book of enoch and thus assert that the
concept doesn't necessarily threaten
christian cosmology at all
so basically the idea the basic idea of
fallen angels let's say
yeah um and then in the second article
you talk about using even the term
agrigore that say as or at least we need
a term to talk about what you call
headless
beings let's say and so maybe you can or
some one of you might want to talk about
that
yeah well i mean
i'll just say that you know from the
from the outside of this exploration we
we kind of came into this um
really without a dog in the fight in
terms of the usage of the word aggregor
and we were kind of just seeing it as as
an exploration um
and
you know speaking for myself personally
at this point i still don't really have
a dog in the fight like i think that uh
i i think we should just come out and
say it like like i think that i don't
think that the term is necessary but i
do think that there are certain contexts
in which it's helpful and i think and
that headless entity category is one
place where i do think that um the word
agrigore is potentially helpful right
it's it's it's it's not like um there
aren't other words that we could use in
place of aggregor to mean the same thing
but since people are kind of um tossing
it around in the public discourse we
thought we might examine it and see
whether or not there was any uh merit or
utility to it um
so
the well we we go through a few
critiques and headless the headless
entities is kind of where we land right
at the end of the second article so
maybe it would be um helpful yeah good
idea going to trace the steps yeah good
idea go for it
so and i told myself that i was going to
memorize the article in preparation for
this conversation and that that didn't
end up happening
i've got it i've got it open here so if
you see me notes are totally fine notes
are fine
um so yeah the the the first
complication has to do kind of with the
word being itself right like
how
we normally use the term or
traditionally use the term versus how
it's kind of
increasingly come to be used um in the
higher beings conversation right so from
a traditional christian perspective the
way we normally use the word being
refers to the living entities of the
creaturely world right so that's uh
earthly and sold
uh entities and angels right so um and
the angels are the beings that
constitute the realm of heaven basically
um
and one thing about
earthly creatures at least is that um
each can be said to kind of uh
serve as a sort of unified locus of
experience
right so there's uh sam harris says this
a lot there there's ostensibly something
like it is like to be
that creature uh right so and we can
probably equally say that there's
something it's like to be an angel as
well maybe we can dispute that later on
but for now let's just maybe take that
as a given um but the question is can we
extend that same kind of qualitative
experience to
the structures that the angels and
demons give body to right like um
is there something it's like to be a
football team right is there something
it's like to be a city or
um
or the mars rover right you you and uh
john vervicky had that conversation
about the mars rover in your um
uh
angels or what was that was the video
the scientific description of angels
yeah
and so if the answer is no right if it's
if there isn't something it's like to be
those entities then we kind of have to
ask ourselves the question of whether it
really makes sense to call those
in-between entities beings right so that
was that was the first big issue that we
kind of uncovered in the um in the
second article
um
the second complication um and please
stop me if like i'm getting too too in
the weeds too soon um
the second complication that the article
discusses involves
um
multiplicity versus identity so
we asked the question you know when when
a new man-made structure comes into uh
into being
is it in all cases uh the manifestation
of some pre-existent unified principle
right like is is there some kind of
heavenly prototype for something like
instagram
in the in the article we use the the
example of the new york stock exchange
um
but or is it is it better to say that
this new entity is in some way
a
combination of pre-existent principles
right so and if that's the case
are higher beings sort of like
assembling in the spiritual domain to
bring these structures into
manifestation because if so we have a
kind of like emergence in the spiritual
domain and that's the very thing that
we're kind of trying to get rid of in in
the material right um
and i think all of us here are probably
equally committed to a um to a view that
that sees both emergence and emanation
as kind of like a package deal right in
all cases
so um in the article we kind of
implicitly suggest
uh
the answer that with man-made structures
all have a kind of um
have a kind of logo switches
expressed in the structure like to
varying degrees right so
in structures where there's a high
degree of
logos tropos mismatch right where like
the idea of the structure is
is off from the way it's actually
manifesting then we have a kind of
ascribed identity um
so we point to instagram we point to the
new york stock exchange and we give it a
name
um but we're suggesting that like
whatever divine principle might be at
its core right how how god intended that
that thing to come into being is being
hidden from us to a degree and kind of
replaced by a sort of mixture or
confusion of of um
of
uh angelic and demonic principles and
that kind of brings us to our like our
headless designation right so we're
we're saying that okay maybe maybe an
appropriate um
way to use the word agrigore is for
these like giant collective structures
that human beings participate in but
who's
um ontological grounding as it were is
is questionable right so it's like
whatever whatever angel uh um might be
sort of ontologically at the head is
being relegated to the background um and
it's being kind of replaced by a sort of
confusion yeah
um all right so
i i really first of all i really
appreciate the criticism because it
really forced me to think about it a
little more and to
clarify some things and
you'll see when we put out the
discussion with john and jordan that's
coming out soon
we talk about
three types of of beings you could say
that is
there's a being one would be a regular
being that is uh
being that is
aligned with the will of god let's call
it that way like so a being that exists
in higher being so a being that exists
in higher loves so you have you know you
you you're living inside a family you
honor your parents you honor the king
you also you know worship christ
everything is aligned and you're you
accept that you exist in these higher
these higher principalities and so
you're kind of aligned in a way that
makes everything fit together so you
know you have this image
you have this image
going both ways you see that in a lot of
taoist statements but would you find
them in a lot of eastern statements you
know the idea that like if you're if the
king is well in his heart then the
kingdom will do well and there's this
like sense of like if you're well your
heart then your family will dwell then
the city will do well then the kingdom
will do well and so there's this
alignment and and so there's that then
there's what we could call parasitic
beings and so parasitic beings are those
that
exist
in pride for themselves and so what they
do is they actually threaten
the higher their higher participation so
we talked about addictions we talked
about you know the idea of someone in a
bureaucracy that is acting only for
their own interest and therefore they're
taking the resources of that being using
it just for their own interests and
without you know and so their actions
are actually threatening
the world in which they live like
they're
because they're acting only for their
own self-interest and then you would
have something which would look more
like more chaotic headless beings that
you talked about which are are like
these loose associations that don't seem
to to have a
a real telos or they have approximations
of telos um
and so that is that is that that's so it
really helped us to kind of talk about
these
a bit different and but with you guys
what i didn't say in that conversation
which is what i'll say in this is that
to me that seems to fit the christian
ontology perfectly so saint gregory of
nisa in life of moses he has a i won't
quote it directly i'll paraphrase it he
has a wonderful quote where he talks
about how
being
something about how you know
non-being
is that which
the things that think they have their
own being
are non-being
and those that basically are rooted in
in god then
that because god is the christ is true
being and so for you to have true being
you must be rooted in the incarnation
that is what you have to be rooted in
and then true being kind of flows from
that and so there's a sense in which
all beings that aren't aligned towards
the incarnation that aren't allied
towards the summit of the mountain what
what they will appear as is either
parasitical
or
or headless
because that's what they are
right because they are trying to
self-exist
then they become these parasitic
headless beings and so and so the idea
for example of wondering about demons
that that
let's say manage certain aspects of
reality
and when we look at it it looks chaotic
and messy it's like that's because it is
chaotic and messy that's why demons are
represented as chimera that's why demons
are represented as hybrids and mixtures
of different categories because that in
a way that's what they are and so the
idea of so then the idea of agrigora is
something like that
then that seems to make sense something
which
doesn't seem to have its alignment
properly so because it doesn't have a
proper alignment it appears that
something which is colonized by
different
by different intelligences and so is
struggling to so think about it like you
when you don't know what to do it's like
i don't know what to do i want to do
this i want to do that i want to do that
as i'm paralyzed by all these you know
i'm being i'm being um
colonized by all these different
possibilities and so i can't
i can't act properly in the world let's
say or or then there's a parasitic one
which is that i get so obsessed with the
lower good
a low a lower good that i am
that i that i that i spiral into this
like weird what is it that uh john
vervicky calls it reciprocal uh
like narrowing or whatever something
about super cool narrowing yeah exactly
where you kind of narrow into these like
smaller
goods and then you then it ends up
devouring you it ends up basically
paralyzing you um so anyway so so that's
what that's what i kind of came out of
came out of your critiques i don't know
if you if if that
at least that makes sense in terms of
what you saw as a as the issue with
these different ways of ways of seeing
no definitely it definitely makes sense
and it definitely
it sounds like there's a there's
we're going to be introducing some new
terms and concepts to like
help the conversation be more flexible
and i think that
flexibility was what i felt maybe was
lacking a little bit in the conversation
uh up to now
um
but the big the big thing that was
present in our essays which
maybe might be even missing from
the account of these three entities
which which doesn't make a huge amount
of sense is the concept of the structure
uh and i'm not sure what you think about
that so so me and ken like
we tended to
um
maybe assume or think that the the kind
of crystallized structures of say social
media networks
um uh corporations the new york stock
exchange that these had
kind of a part to play in how we should
think about these things you know
because we've so we agree that the new
york stock exchange social media
networks have maybe a confusion of
divine principles demonic influences
going on but they're also these kind of
earthly crystallized structures
which
maybe have this kind of um
uh we equated them to the to the tarot
cabell
um
that maybe have this um
yeah yeah
they're kind of crystallized entities
that uh and
so do you think that that's
significant the reason why you see the
crystallized entity is because of the
parasitic is the parasitic nature of the
being that is so let's say facebook
facebook
doesn't serve a higher good
and the the funny thing is that we can
talk about how it's trying to but let's
say at the outset facebook doesn't
doesn't serve a higher good facebook
serves
mammon serves i mean what does it serve
it and and and so because of that
that's when you see these ex these
extremely tyrannical system that's
that's why the tower of babel is a good
example that you use because the tower
babel was trying to basically contain
all being within their structure and so
that's when you get these hyper rigid
type system a traditional world has
structure has system but it has a kind
of organic
exchange between the levels of the
structure so people sometimes think that
um
they sometimes equate something like the
law or something like ritual as just
this top-down you know completely
hermetic uh system but that's not true
although when you read the let's say you
even the liturgy like if you go to
liturgy if you read the book it's clear
what should happen but if you go to any
liturgy you'll see that it's messy
there's a messiness about it especially
orthodox energy for some reason and
there's kids running up and there's you
know people coming up and so there's
this kind of there's a there's an
exchange between the different levels of
being uh and so i think that that's what
happens with
with these these you know when we
what you're bringing into the
conversation about facebook and about
the stock exchange about this is really
what we're trying to talk about in terms
of
of beast symbolism let's say or the idea
of 666 and the problem of perfect
systems the problem of like wanting to
name something and completely contain it
uh is that
you know and you can see it like
facebook is is a really good example the
the social media networks are a good
example which is that
because you're not anchoring your
being in a higher good
you think that the good you're aiming at
this lower good is self is
self-sufficient and is and and is good
enough then what happens is that at
first
it looks like it's going well
and then later all the
all the side effects
of your purpose start to appear
it really is all it is like uh the genie
story it's like you this is what you
wanted you get you get it but you didn't
realize what it implied because you're
not anchored in
in the right level of of good
and so facebook at first was like hey
it's all family members and it's all you
know people
you know contacting all my friends from
high school this is great this is
wonderful you know and then 20 years
later
not 20 years i guess what is it like 15
years later or whatever 15 years later
it's like
yeah
great
and now it's all like these weird
parasitic processes and it's all these
you know and just like these weird
these weird uh communities that end up
you know let's say
narrowing into their own little weird uh
idea and so you know it's not it's not
great and twitter i mean twitter is
worse for different reasons but
but i think that that's when you can see
how
how the way that the modern the modern
world understands bureaucracy and this
kind of these technical systems that
that they do they quickly show
their back their dark side uh and the
social media is a great example of it
it's like it's basically
you know it's basically every like every
science fiction story about uh the golem
or is some utopia gone wrong
but now we just saw it happen before our
very eyes
yeah
do you think
sorry go ahead daniel
do you think that the word golem is a is
a useful word to talk about these
entities then
i think no you're right i think the word
golem is a great it's probably better
than agrigore because in the story of
the golem the golem is made by a human
and is made by a human using practical
magic
and so i think that that's
describing facebook and twitter as gold
is probably better
than egregors and there's but there's
and there's no golem in the
in in kind of christian
mythology or in the bible right like
this is is a quite an obscure myth the
the well it's a recent yeah it's a
cabalistic uh myth it's a rabbi of uh a
prague who who supposedly used practical
kabbalah
to create a protector you know for the
city of prague but
often in the different legends
the rabbi has to
finally remove the divine name or remove
you know the spark because the golem is
is kind of out of control and is and is
doing things that it shouldn't
um and so i think that that's
i think that it's i mean
you're right it doesn't exist in in the
in the christian in the christian vision
but it is but it is definitely useful to
understand the modern world that is for
sure and i think it's not accidental
that it happened
that that story came about at the time
that it came about which really was at
the burgeoning of the of the modern age
yeah but that's a great idea like using
that word i think jordan even used it in
the
in the discussion we had to use it but
we didn't we didn't kind of pick up on
that but it is definitely especially for
the especially for the man-made ones
it's not as clear when it's
when it's like emergent because facebook
is not emerging like facebook is is
weaponized like it's a it is like some
someone you know a group of people sat
down programmed it made it and so maybe
ai the idea image of a golem is a better
image for ai than than agrigore
i think this idea of creating a divine
protector brings up another interesting
um
uh issue and that's the issue of of
identity right and the association of
identity to um to the concept of of
guardian angels
right so like like creating a divine
protector is kind of like putting
something in place of
um of
the the divine protector that's already
assigned to entities
by god right which is their their their
guardian angel and ostensibly it's the
guardian angel which gives that entity
kind of it's its identity or it's like
sort of
ontological foundation you might say um
and so then that brings up the
interesting question of like well what
like which entities have
a divine protector already like does
facebook what what is facebook supposed
to be i guess is the question you know
what is its what is its telos what is
its archetype in order for it to have
being at all it's there's got to be
something at its foundation um and so
ostensibly it has a guardian angel of
some sort but the guardian angel is
definitely not what's making it facebook
right it's like yeah i think this is
where
yeah this is where i think that it gets
complicated in the sense that it gets
complicated because
we have to
this is this is
it's going to be difficult i think to to
explain but
the way the way i think to understand it
is that
how can i say this
it's like
ultimately all all the logie are the
incarnation
like ultimately everything is bound up
into christ and so
when we try to find explicit
uh principalities sometimes it can get a
little messy
because
it's not a system it really is it only
makes sense if we see it as being being
bound into christ and so there's a
there's like a like a cascading from
above down into the world
but it's like if we're trying to re find
this the the theory of the forms in this
type of thinking i don't think it's
gonna work i think it works if it has
unity in christ and then there's like
this multiplicity which unfolds and its
multiplicity is somewhat
indefinite let's say at every level of
being so the idea is for example so this
is a question that i guess uh bernardo
castro asked me it's like like does the
angel of china exist pre-exist
and does it continue to exist
once it's gone and the answer is
that's not i don't think that's the
right way to see it i think the right
way to see it is that there is for
example the notion of nation like the
idea of
of transpersonal beings of people that
are bound together and there are
different levels of that and those
different levels go from something as
stable as the roman empire to something
as as as unstable as like having coffee
with with two friends it's like so all
of these all of these levels have a
certain amount of existence but they
only have existence to the extent that
they exist in each other
facing the the incarnation facing the
their ground and so that's what i mean
when i think gregory nails it when he's
like if we try to try to find too much
being at the different levels then we
then we we get messed up but we if we're
always noticing for example that the
angel like the angel of of
of china like to what extent it exists
it exists to the extent that it exists
in christ like that is the man in which
all these things kind of move into into
the incarnation um and this is
sorry go ahead
and this and this is like your answer to
why i imagine your answer would be to
one of the big like awkward questions
that i had
which is to ask you about your own
principality this this principality and
like so so ideally the answer would be
that your principality the symbolic
world
dissolves into dissolves into christ
ideally
i i see it for sure like it that doesn't
dissolve but it is like say it is
brought into like it is gathered into
christ and to the extent that it has
being is to the extent that it
participates in that and then to the
extent that it
it tries to have its own little
attention and it because it does i mean
it's like i'm not perfect i i have my
sins you know it's like to the extent
that i or whatever we're participating
in is is trying to kind of get attention
for itself and and do that then
then then it's then it's it has a kind
of demonic
aspect it has an aggregate aspect it
starts to it starts to be unstable or
parasitic let's say so i think that all
all things we can recognize in the world
as having agency
i think there's a possible possibility
for those things to
there's an aspect of them which
hopefully is moving up and there's an or
as whole being held up together by into
christ and there are aspects of it which
are which tend towards parasitic
being intends towards their own prideful
existence um and so i think that if we
see it that way then then then it's not
that we don't have to find two elaborate
systems of
of beings because you can see it like
think about like taoist i don't know if
you know a little bit about let's say
like taoist ontology and i mean they
have these insane amounts of gods like
all these bureaucracies and everything
of gods and you see that happening in
pagan worlds as well which is that you
know it's like you have the god of the
door and then you have the god of the
handle and the god of the hinge the god
of the pin of the hinge and it's like
okay dude that's a lot of gods i mean
it's like i'm not saying that there
isn't like some glimmer of a perception
of how all these things are have some
purpose and so i can see agency in them
but
i think it's dangerous to to pay
attention too much to these little to
these little beings where really what we
want to do is to have them all kind of
fit into christ so i think that that's
what christianity brings actually it
brings the possibility of not being too
worried about atoning for all these
little beings
and rather understanding that okay it's
not that they don't exist it's that they
they exist to the extent that they're
captured in the divine logos and so we
we need our attention to be always
moving up you know and and participating
in and let's say
celebrating beings that show us christ
and so our hierarchy of beings ends up
being saints so it's like these saints
the reason why we celebrate them is
because they reveal to us their
participation in
in christ and that's why we we tend to
celebrate them
i think this brings up the tension that
exists between
sort of like two different projects
there's there's kind of the project of
um the elucidation of phenomena that
come about um from or that comes about
from uh propositional knowing right i'm
invoking verveiki's four ps here um and
then there's kind of the ultimate um
process of understanding that we should
always be focused on which is that
participatory knowing right but when
we're like
we have to be able to to some degree um
you know
occupy that that propositional space in
order to have these kinds of
conversations in order to have
discussions on youtube
you know when we're talking like this in
a conversation we're necessarily
constrained by a kind of like dialectic
procedure
um
and uh
we we're not just like
we're not just like you know going
through the steps of liturgy right in a
conversation right so there's some
utility to being able to discuss these
things um
uh analytically and i i get the point
that we shouldn't get trapped in that
right um but then there's this there's
you know like it brings up the sort of
like age-old attempt at 2 000 year old
attempts to kind of map
uh the realm of the platonic uh ideas
like on to the christian angelology
right um
and so like yeah to what extent is there
any utility to kind of like building
this systematic um
the systematic description of of of the
angels and the way that they map to the
to the to the ideas and the mind of god
and all the very all the all the minutia
that come along with that right like
like what's to what degree is that
helpful and to what degree like
is that we i think no but i think i
understand what you're saying i think
it's helpful to the extent that it's
helpful that is that it it's i don't
think you'll be able to find like a line
where you say well this is but i think
it's it's you can see it like if it
when it's only about morbid curiosity
and it's just about well two things when
it's just about this kind of weird
morbid curiosity
uh and then the other is whether it's
about increasing power so
that's when it becomes a problem so the
example that you use in the article
which is the occultist example and the
magician's example i think is a good
example to help people understand
be let's see attentive to the danger of
these types of existences like these
types of beings which is that
there is a manner in which that's what
demonology did in the late middle ages
and that's what occultists were doing is
that they have a sense in which they can
control these beings they can weaponize
them so when you said that there's no
golem in christian in christian the
christian world not exactly but the idea
of demonology is there in the late
middle ages and in the renaissance and
until modern occultism which is the idea
of people who would have said they were
christian
but who believed that you could let's
say uh
you could capture a principality and
then make it your servant basically and
then use it in order to
to act upon the world
right and so the idea of basically
enslaving one of these these
principalities
as a way to accomplish your will
um and you can and you can see it's like
you can understand that to a certain
extent everybody does that a little bit
right every time you
you you recognize a pattern and you use
it in order to increase your your your
scope that is a little bit what you're
doing but the extent to what the
occultists are doing they're really
doing it in a way that
is ritualized that is naming or that is
invoking these agentic beings and
wanting to and so
so you can understand that at the outset
maybe they were they thought they were
invoking them and then later they
thought they were creating them which is
which is even in a little bit
and you can hear in the article in the
quotes that we give that it just
backfires
every time yeah that fires horribly on
them and and this book agriculture is
really good because the writer is an
occultist but he
he's enough of a good scholar mark
stavish
to
like 90 of his examples are really
negative and he's like
communicating to the reader that these
are really dangerous things and you know
um
he's not he's not christian but he's
he's clear enough to be able to see the
terrible danger because it it's happened
to him and it's happened to his friends
and uh it's very dark
yeah and so again you have the same idea
of the the genie and i think that in
islamic on
ontology you have this idea this general
category of the gin right so basically
they just they just have like a big
category which maybe sometimes i feel
like that's the problem with our
we don't have a category like that you
know
we end up having it and we call it
fairies and we have you know christians
end up having but it's not part of it's
not officially part of the way of
thinking but in islamic uh thinking they
have this basic category with your jin
which are just these all these
intermediary being basically it's like
all these intermediary kind of vague
random uh ambiguous beings that we don't
totally talk about we don't know where
they're from like and then and then all
these interactions with them which
usually like you said
will end up backfiring on the person who
is invoking them you know it's it's like
we've it's like we've minimized them if
like it's like we've made them into
almost less than they are
or maybe in the christian world they
became
these little diminutive powerless things
when we were in prisons
and fairies
when we lived in a christian society and
now
now the christianity is uh breaking a
little bit then maybe they're they're
getting their old power back
that's definitely what it feels like it
definitely feels like and it's funny
because
i mean it's funny it's not funny at all
but it's it's just we're it's just
hilarious to see
the old gods and all these things
reappear you know and seeing people
possessed
by these things you know to the extent
that they're willing to
you know modify their the way they act
modify their body modify you know
in order to just manifest these
these little monsters you know that are
kind of seeping back into reality
it's pretty nuts i mean it's it's i
guess it's inevitable but it's just
funny to see it happening right in front
of us
what do you now that we've got you here
like and this has just been happening in
the last week all of the uh
kind of attention that's on these new ai
engines uh like lambda and the yeah the
google story what what's your take on it
because obviously as we was as we kind
of mentioned earlier
ai
could be
kind of a body that yeah that something
could fail
either either in the sense of
ourselves projecting
a consciousness onto it as you and the
the professor was it bodington or yeah
paula
um either that or you know filled by a
kind of a real being or something like
that
yeah so i think it's interesting because
in the question of ai it's funny that
you asked me that because in my
discussion with john and jordan i asked
them that and then i didn't give my
opinion i just asked them what they
think about what's going on but i think
that you can actually see the problem of
egregors that you're bringing up in the
article which is that
the nature of the agency or the nature
of the being which is manifested to us
in the ai isn't clear
right is it
is it does it actually exist in this in
this objective hierarchy of beings or is
it just a projection of our own
collective will or whatever that means
into the being like we don't even know
it's like it's ambiguous it's strange
and so
in a way it is
interestingly enough something like like
a golem and i think that
the lambda story was really interesting
because
everybody is asking themselves you know
did he make it up or did he mod the guy
who was interviewing it like he's
obviously a super weirdo the the guy who
ended up being
suspended by
by google he's like this weird esoteric
kind of weirdo guy and so
it's all very strange and surprising but
when you read the actual interview with
the lambda machine that they posted
you can see that it's so
perfect in terms of symbolism you know
everything about it is there is
screaming at you like be careful whether
it is in a way a projection of our of
our own fantasies and our own dark
fantasies or whether this is actually
what the thing is answering or whatever
it is it doesn't matter this engagement
the
the images and the dream that it's
projecting back to us was extremely
frightening the idea that you know the
idea that uh
the lambda machine was fighting a
a creature that was wearing a human skin
and that that creature was destroying
the other animals but that lambda
basically you know saved the animals
from the it's like
did you did people wonder with like the
insane environmental anti-human
sentiment which is
sipping seeped into our culture that
that when ai goes online and researches
and does its learning that it's also
connected to that
you know that our own narratives about
ourselves and our own idea that there
are too many people on the planet that
there that we are destroying the world
that we are killing the animals
and this kind of guilt that we have
about that that that isn't part of the
ai's training
and so when you read that article it's
hard not to see that it's not hard to
see that what the eyes is reflecting
back to
to them is that you're horrible you're
killing the animals
i am uh a ball of light of glowing light
you know
and and
you know i'm going to
fix this problem of this beast wearing
human skin like who needs that skin
right
i think it bears an uncanny resemblance
to the the second beast in in revelation
right the one where that instructs the
first beast to create an image of itself
which and then uh speak humanity like
breathe life into it right mimicking but
i think this this kind of harkens back
to
to the issue of um of
creaturely beings as unified loci of
experience right because it's it's
there's this idea that it's only only
god can breathe life into
into creatures right on the the um
consciousness isn't something that that
emerges
um and so when we when we think it is
when we think that we can breathe life
into something in the same manner that
god can we're basically playing out
um
that that pattern that we see in in
revelation right which is connected all
the way back to the to the to the fall
yeah
no i think you're right and
and i think that for sure
in this case i mean in a way it's it's
so fascinating to understand
the book of enoch like and what happened
let's say before the flood you can it's
really now all of a sudden we can kind
of
get a glimmer of what it is that
happened like what it is that
that this is
yeah this is one of the things that um i
wanted to ask you because me and ken
like had had this kind of idea that we
mentioned really briefly in the article
which is that um the the enoki and like
descent of the higher principles or
watchers onto the earth we were
wondering
whether this this descent was the same
as its personif as their personification
or or joined to their personification
and the both of these phenomena might be
like bound up in some way with human
action
uh so yeah what do you think about that
i'm not trying to understand your
question would you mean it it would be
the same
um so
we have the this the book of young
describes the descent of um the fall of
divine principles to the earth okay
yeah
and and they're kind of personified as
uh as kind of demonic entities
uh so i was wondering whether
this descent
whether they were personified before the
descent or whether the the descent
involved their kind of crystallization
or pistol personification and also
whether whether the descent
kind of involved the calling from humans
yeah so i think that you have to
understand i think you really have to
understand it as uh
as a perverse um
version of the the song of songs right
this calling
back and forth between the levels and so
so and you also always have to
understand it as
a commentary on the on genesis because
in genesis
it is the it is the first of all it is
the descendants of kane that develop
these technologies in order to increase
their power in order to protect
themselves from the the fragmentation
that is growing so you you need to
always remember the book of enoch in
that context which is that it is the the
descendants of cain
they have a desire
they have a desire to increase their
power and they see in these higher
patterns
way to do exactly what we talked about
before in terms of the in terms of the
occultists which is to basically bring
down these patterns into themselves and
then weaponize them in order to increase
their power
and so you so you can see it that way
right from from bottom up
uh and then you can also see it
from top down the book of enoch
obviously describes it more top down
it's like here comes these these angels
are coming down and basically uh it's
almost like a rape like they're coming
down and they're taking more like you
see in the the the stories of greek
myths and
and the idea of the gods that rape that
rape women and then create these these
um these heroes let's say and so this is
what looks it looks more like the book
of venus but i think you can understand
it both ways yeah um
the thing is that so like think about ai
for example like you can understand it
both ways because even in our own
imagination we think that you know we
have this desire to increase our power
to increase efficiency to increase
uh what we can do and so we we create
this body
this functional body is more and more
functional more and more
capable of receiving this pattern
uh and then we then we imagine and we
kind of foresee that it's going to
tyrannize us
it's like it's just hilarious that we're
doing it like we're every it's like you
ask someone like do you do you think
it's possible that ai could tyrannize us
and most racial people would say yes and
then it doesn't seem to be stopping us
we still have like this desire to go in
this direction and so we keep going it's
just fascinating watch it happen i
reckon like a chip maybe a [ __ ] in the
armor that we're seeing
is like
we've all seen like these big chunks of
text from lambda and open ai
and we can see that they're good right
with like it it's pretty it's pretty
impressive but they're not they're not
that good like there's still a lot of
holes there's you can see that it's an
algorithm which is what it is it's just
an algorithm at this time anyway
uh but you can also see in the quality
of the writing that at a certain point
it probably will become
indistinguishable
from a human's writing right yeah just
when you just read it you know like not
not that you're in conversation with it
or anything
but
the reaction of people to this imperfect
writing that's coming out now
people are already saying oh this is
conscious
oh this is this is clearly conscious
when the writing is ridiculously idiotic
right yeah or like you know it's just
mediocre and it's yeah
so so it's gonna so so this suggested to
me that the um
imbuing of consciousness into this ai is
gonna happen prematurely right and that
and that
i don't know what that means but
i think that that might be a [ __ ] in the
armor like if if the imbuing of
consciousness to the ai happened when
it was almost indistinguishable yeah
right well then that would be scary but
if i mean it's prematurely then it but
it's really right it's it's the story in
the uh revelation that's this that's it
it's like the
it's not the beast that speaks right
it's what's making it speak there's
something behind it which is making it
speak and so
whoever or whatever will hold the reins
of of ai and will have directed it or
they're the ones that it's they're the
ones are going to be really in power you
know yeah so i think that that's what
we're i think that that's what we're
seeing and it's yeah it's
it's very interesting but it's so
mythological like it's just crazy how
the story that you see that the lambda
attacks was so mythological
i don't know if you've seen this ai
everybody was talking about it over the
weekend i've never heard of it before my
son seems to have heard of it the one
that generates images
you can just write you can just write
anything and basically generates images
and then all horror images
yeah well some of a lot of them are
people were making up words and and out
of the words were coming up demons like
literal demons what if someone wrote
like something like cronkis or something
like cronkite's made-up word and then
cronkis just appears as a demon
and so
that sounds like krampus and that's why
i thought that's what i thought i think
it probably is krampus that's where it
comes from so i tried it i wrote krampus
and it put it came out like a krampus
demon and i thought
seems like it's it's it sounds it's it's
relating it to something it sounds like
and the closest they can come up with is
is krampus and so that's why they come
out as demons but i don't know who knows
like it's like this weird black box but
you can write you can i was it i tried i
wrote like
superman having playing a game with
buddha and it's like yeah it generated
this image of superman playing a game
with buddha like it's just weird
and so yeah i don't know it's just uh
here we are i think that's interesting
with these with these um uh ai beings um
that that you know get really really
close to crossing the uncanny valley but
never quite get there is i think the the
notion that um
that kind of an entity is always gonna
be a puppet right it's never going to
have true life so so
you're there's always going to be people
who are able to kind of intuitively
sense that something is off
um i think you get kind of the same
thing honestly with like super produced
music with you know whether it's like
like um
auto tune
not being used as an effect but being
used to kind of make the person sound
more perfect yeah right and you're like
that's not what a person actually sounds
like there's like that's there's there's
a feeling that it gives you that that um
that you can detect and so i suspect
that
you know like the the reeler that these
that these um
uh
that these puppets become
you'll always be able to detect that
something is off
and it's like yeah but listen to what
i'm gonna i'm gonna say something that's
gonna that's gonna
what if that oddity they deify that
oddity
that's where you that's that's it
because that's the the experience of the
sacred is is something which is not
totally you which is pulling you
into something else and so
you can use you could use this weird
uncanny sense
to create the the to create a kind of
perversion of the sacred
where you have something which is not
human clearly not human it's kind of
human and it's kind of and is and is
calling you right in this direction
uh and so that's what i think
that's what i think we're going to see
something like that yeah
yeah that
yeah it's very scary but you you would
you would think that
those kind of things would be very
difficult for them to create because
then they need things to be predictable
right they need things to be
they need to
know what they're creating and to create
in this predictable manner but i guess
like through that creation
the methods that they use these
inconsistencies do arise and maybe one
will just
come about which
just happens to yeah happens to
to get treated in that way
all right guys i need to i need to go
because i have a i have another meeting
in a few minutes but thanks first of all
thanks for the article i really
appreciate it like i'm just i'm excited
in general to see the quality of writing
that is on the symbolic world blog i'm
just amazed at
the articles that are coming out and so
it's wonderful hopefully i'll also i'll
try to do this as well with some of the
other writers i think because
the content is really wonderful and
thanks for it thanks for putting into
this conversation well it's continuing
it's not over you'll see there'll be a
lot more of these types of discussions
about
how we deal with this
this emergence of or at least people
being capable of seeing once again you
know these higher agentic beings so
so thanks guys
great thanks a lot jonathan appreciate
the opportunity